it can be painfully easy to hit what we
call a crisis of meaning in these
moments we feel the following what I'm
doing makes no sense
I'm not contributing to anything I'm
living day to day repeating things for a
logic I just don't understand at such
points it can help to step back and
consider something we don't usually
address what is the meaning of existence
for the species as a whole what is the
underlying narrative logic of the mess
full starts occasional progress and
fitful paths of human history the
200,000 year old history of Homo sapiens
by this we don't of course mean a
god-given meaning we mean a logic that
drives human behavior at its best the
most generous interpretation of what
knits human action when it isn't driven
by evil motives here we can make the
following deliberately rather bold
declarations there are four drivers of
meaning in the human race firstly to
continue the species secondly to master
our minds understand ourselves thirdly
to master our environment increasing our
command over it through knowledge
control of resources and the reduction
of the role of accident and misfortune
and fourthly
the increase of our satisfaction these
vast headings help to explain a lot of
our day-to-day activity take the human
Drive of continuing the species which
explains parenting courtship love take
mastering our minds and understanding
ourselves that explains philosophy
psychology education even media
mastering the environment that explains
business defense science architecture
and as for our quest for happiness
this explains religion culture art it's
because of our need to master the
environment that we store up capital
it's because we're collectively engaged
in continuing the species that we become
parents it's in order to reduce the role
of random accidents that we have science
crucially these four drives our vast
collective movements and no one human
ever makes more than a tiny contribution
to any of
them from a sufficient distance even
so-called great names Shakespeare in
Newton Einstein and John F Kennedy only
ever add a little bit to the unfolding
river of humanity the greatest might
adjust its course by a millimeter
naturally in relation to the mighty
goals of humanity each of us is puny and
therefore measuring our contribution
individually is bound to leave us
feeling defeated we shouldn't be doing
this we should think that we are but
temporary actors of a species with
broadly collective goals though our
goals can feel very personal to us when
for example we're building up our own
business with just partaking in the
species will to master the environment
and husband resources for a while the
history of humanity unfolds in time we
only ever make our contribution at one
moment and the changing circumstances
mean that our achievements do risk
seeming absurd at another point in time
a very important nobleman in 14th
century England is mere dust now we
remember almost no human who lived in
the 11th century almost nothing stands
out in the whole of the ninth century
all those people who lived and died are
as nothing this is similar to what will
happen to us today we can tell by
looking backwards and anticipating
forwards that very little of what we do
could conceivably have much of an impact
nevertheless we can at best see
ourselves as making a contribution to
the goals of humankind maybe over a
lifetime we'll collect a few resources
we'll understand a few bits of the
puzzle of the mind we'll have children
who will have children who will have
children will alleviate the suffering of
a few other people it won't be much on
its own but we shouldn't measure it on
its own that is the sickness of
individualism we have to measure it
against a broad stream of what humanity
is up to in James Joyce's portrait of
the artist as a young man there's a
charming moment where Stephen Dedalus
who's nine years old and central
character write his name in a geography
book in a way that positions him in
space he begins
Stephen Dedalus class of elements clong
gauss would college sale ins County
Kildare Ireland Europe the world the
universe all of us exist in these kind
of multiple dimensions the immediate the
classroom where in our own name and the
grand within the universe we need to do
a version of this positioning exercise
except we're not looking for
geographical positioning we're looking
for purpose positioning none of us is
going to make a huge contribution to the
history of the meaning of the species we
will just tinker with one or two
elements we'll have kids we'll make a
bit of money we'll understand
one or two things so we have to take
species pride and reconcile ourselves to
our smallness in the larger scheme but
it can still help us to know that a
connection exists between what we're up
to and what the grander story of
humanity means if today you made some
money that's connected to humanity
attempting to master its environment if
today you looked after some children
you'll have furthered in a tiny way the
survival of the species if today you
taught someone something will have
continued our attempt to understand the
human condition if today you tidied up
the house you helped to make life be
slightly less random and accident-prone
what we call being depressed means not
being able to find oneself on the grid
of meaning not being able to plot one's
own coordinates on the map of the
meaning of humanity but if we look the
right way everything can be connected
when it's almost always in some way
helping to continue and enhance the
project of our species we just need to
get better at spotting meaning at
narrating the meaning of one's life in
relation to the meaning of a whole
species we publish new thought-provoking
films every week be sure to subscribe to
our Channel and take a look at more of
what we have to offer at the link on
your screen now
you